هل هذا جيد إلى لوسيا لقد
كنت شيئًا أمتلكه في اليوم السابق
لعيد الميلاد ،
كان على هذه الفتاة الصغيرة السعيدة البالغة من العمر أربع سنوات والتي تتمتع بصحة جيدة أن
تنتقل إلى مستشفى الأطفال
في جامعة أيوا بينما كان والداها
يشاهدان مرعوبين لم أفكر  كنت
سأصبح سوريًا في تلك المرحلة ،
لم أكن مصابًا بالأنفلونزا ، وهي سلالة تسمى
الإنفلونزا B ، فهي تنتشر بسرعة في
جميع أنحاء البلاد وهو أمر
غير معتاد للغاية في هذا الوقت من العام
ويقول الخبراء إن أكثر الفئات عرضة للإصابة بها
هم الأطفال في طب الأطفال المكثف
وحدة الرعاية Jade كانت لا تستجيب ،
جهاز التنفس الصناعي يتنفس بسبب الإنفلونزا
B ينشط جهاز المناعة الخاص بها
ليبدأ في مهاجمة أعضائها على
وجه التحديد الدماغ ويسبب
تورمًا في الدماغ لأيام
لم تكن والدتها وأمها يعرفان ما الذي
سيجلبه لها الأطباء في المستقبل.
قد لا يجعل الأمر يؤلمك فقط
، إنه يمزق قلبك لأنك
تريدها فقط أن تستيقظ أيها الأب السماوي ،
نطلب منك فقط أن تلتف
حول الملائكة حول Jade هذا مور  نينج
وطوال اليوم أصلي من أجل الشفاء اليوم ، ثم
أخيرًا بعد ما يقرب من أسبوعين ،
استيقظت Jade Jade ، شعرت وكأنها معجزة ولكن
بعد ذلك لاحظ أطبائها شيئًا
وجده Unicorn Jade لا يمكنه رؤيتي ،
تسبب البراغيث في التهاب في دماغها
و  قد تكون عمياء إلى الأبد ،
يعلم والداها أن جايد لا يزال أمامها طريق طويل
لتقطعه في شفائها جاي ، هل تشعر أنك
بخير كلا وهم مذهولون بما
يمكن أن تفعله الأنفلونزا لطفل سليم إليزابيث
كوهين.